a family photo that's not at all creepy
except for that guy and Super Mario
Brothers turns 25 years old today
it's Episode four of IMG today Kotaku
brought us the 10 most bizarre ipad mods
a USB typewriter and ipad arcade and
even an ipad skateboard hot on Digg
right now fantastic post-it note art
they've got wallpaper donkey kong mario
Megaman and a big fu to 2d we've really
got to cover this one last week
duh Mitch calm collected some of jeffrey
Scott Campbell's greatest disney for
adults work enjoy
[Music]
by a BuzzFeed's collection last week
morbidly obese Disney Princesses
I actually found these for the first
time this week artist Larry Kagan
Creed's abstract wire art for walls at
first it just looks like wire spaghetti
bar but when you turn on the lights BAM
the structures are built to cast clean
accurate shadows of common shapes
sometimes they even meld with the
shadows to create one super scary cool
picture but there are definitely
pictures creepier than just shadows
bunnies cats and the most terrifying of
them all what a dick
screw it let's move on to illusions I
first saw this when I was a psychology
student but if you guys haven't seen it
yet it's worth it stare at the center
dot and don't let your eyes move slowly
the circle of pink dots will completely
disappear until you move your eyes and
they pop back into place and here's a
brightness illusion from the annual TED
conference this color is exactly the
same as this color seriously
lay your finger over the crease and
without the depth clues the colors match
are you ready for a doozy put your
finger on the red dot and concentrate go
ahead good good now wait and whoa you
guys are a bunch of bunt touches let's
move on to facebook.com slash vsauce
gaming this is the place where you guys
can submit your favorite images from
each week my favorite submissions from
last week were crazy trees when I saw
this and this I look like this that does
it for episode 4 of IMG I'll see you
next week and in the meantime check out
our Facebook page to see what others are
submitting thanks for watching subscribe
for more bye bye
[Music]